bedecken immer mehr Leute
was ist das für ein Pinguin oder was ist
das der Kloster bin ich 88 Jahren
[Musik]
können
die meisten noch
sehr verschlafen
Kloster hätten eigenen Zugang zu der
Kirche
sind da
also
ein Ort wo man
sieht sondern
ich merke vielfachen Zug das Lied auch
extra Abteilung wenn es nicht sind
also es geht doch immer was ist das für
Pinguin oder was ist das so
liebe
merkt ja aber also für da bin jetzt also
guten Morgen das ist schön Gabriela
das freut mich
viel grüßen
der Herr ist mit ihr Gebetszeiten
die Völker sollen dir danken Robert
singe dem Herrn ein neues Lied denn er
hat wunderbar getan
was für eine Standard
[Musik]
danke vielmals
Kärlicher
geschlafen
eigentlich Leiterin genau
leider also das wäre schon alles
miteinander
[Musik]
er wählt hinter Muhre sieht über 400
Jahren Benediktinerinnen
[Musik]
die älteste Schwester ist 95
Durchschnittsalter ist
vor vier Jahren ins Kloster Wikon und
Kloster Melchtal aufsamen
ah da heißt wenn ich wie alt bist 22
[Musik]
ab will die katholische Kirche
der Herr seine Torch
es segne euch daran mächtige Gott der
Vater und der Sohn und der Heilige Geist
in der Schweiz ist gut ein Drittel von
der Bevölkerung katholisch das ist die
größte Glaubensgemeinschaft ähnlich
viele sind ohne Religion ein Fünftel
sind reformiert
Ruth maria ist 51 als junge Frau hat sie
verschiedene Glaubensrichtungen
auf der Suche nach Gott Hexe
grundsätzlich ist
[Musik]
aber es gibt Menschen
verunglückt ist mit dem Auto den
wieso hat das müssen passiert
ich denke je nach Lebensituation wo du
dich befindest stimmig
also und das sogar wie dir wo das ganze
Leben eigentlich
ich glaube das gehört einfach zum Leben
Ladina
fein Ladina
oder et labora Betten und Schafe nach
dem motto-lebend Benediktinerinnen aber
wichtig im Tagesablauf und Menge bringt
sie ein im Himmel gerade
[Musik]
Mittag geht's Punkt Viertel jeder Tag
der Ablauf
und das verbindet uns aber ist
eigentlich so wir sind nicht die beste
Freundin
sondern
eigentlich ist es gemeinsame Ziel ja
was machen
[Musik]
für der Ruf von Gott auf Familie
verzichten über der grosse Entscheidung
[Musik]
Form Tini home runter gut
noch Morgenandacht und morgen hat mich
Twister Gabriela ihres Reich bestellt im
Garten
[Musik]
aber sie schauen
das Handy das mache ich viel mit dem
Spiel
läuft
okay also sogar ihren Kloster ins
Problem wir alle
was machen okay
[Musik]
anders zu machen das ist vielleicht
irgendeiner andere Form für weiterleiten
[Musik]
ich Familie verzichten wie schwer ist
die aber gefallen
ja
zum Teil hätte ich Bedürfnis nach
Familie so nach DDR Art von Geborgenheit
es gibt ja
warum heißt jetzt gerade Jesus mies
geworden ich bin doch gar nicht so
partnerlich
also Sexualität machen
[Musik]
zum Traditionen hinterfrage und Alt
aufbrechen
[Musik]
truth Maria Buschow ist sie 3 Jahren
ihres Wort hat Gewicht wenn es um zu
Zukunft vom Kloster geht
[Musik]
weiß nicht ob sie trief ist aber
grundsätzlich ja weil es heißt es geht
wieder mal einer Frau alle sind gleich
von
[Musik]
setzen im letzten Jahr sind in der
Schweiz über 34.000
[Musik]
genau wunderbar
ich hoffe
und schwitze mit damit gewinnen
für später einfach das richtig passiert
[Musik]
mittlerweile
Pilgerinnen und Pilger züchten
Legende seit mehabies im 14 Jahrhundert
zum
als was gilt das also
für mich spielt weniger
Menschen
und haben mit einerseits wirklich
Gesundheit zurück rüber oder für die
Frauen wünsche dass sie genau wieder
können wir da zurück und zeigen
[Musik]
ganz unterschiedliche Sachen
gute Mieter bekommen also sehr
weltlicher Sachen
sie fällt in die Einsamkeit das tut mir
so weh Aufforderung
unser Großer ist gestern verstorben es
war immer gern an diesem Ort achte gut
auf sie im Himmel
das neue interessant was man also dass
ich jetzt gefühlt habe
so glauben dass ich eh nur bis für
ältere was aufgewachsen sind und die
jüngere verlieren
[Musik]
sie sind jetzt auch noch
solche
ja und jetzt reden
[Musik]
Druck im Kloster
schön ja schön
Francesca Leipzig 58 Jahren
geschlossenen
ist klar dass sie die letzten sind und
Kloster ausstiert wenn nicht passiert
[Applaus]
Schwester Gabriela
unabhängig davon wie es sich entwickelt
wichtig ist dass die Wallfahrt also der
Ort erhalten bleibt
zum Jesuskind ich glaube zur Zukunft
aber ich hatte ja nicht sagen ich Form
und wo sich das wir durchgestalten aber
ich glaube ich denke die Art vom
zurückzogene Leben oder auf der Suche
nach dem Sinn vom Leben ich glaube dass
das überdurchschnitt ist
aber auch faszinierend aufgenommen
[Musik]